I don't know about you but I generally
rather play my own protagonist than play
a predetermined one there's something
about having the freedom to make a
character in both terms of aesthetics
and skillset that I really love I see
games like Mass Effect as a sort of
middle ground where Shepard will always
be shepherd but she's my shepherd
because of the choices I've made to
shape her appearance and personality
horizon zero dawn doesn't leave you much
room to shape a personality for a Loy in
fact she may be one of the most fleshed
out characters I've encountered in a
game horizon does have a system we can
opt to respond with compassion logic or
heavy-handedness in some conversations
but they're relatively small alterations
to the concrete person a light already
is before you came along if you're
looking for some guy hype advice or
clips of a boy in action be sure to
subscribe for horizon videos but for now
let's talk about what makes a Lloyd such
a great character alloy has had it rough
she's been outcast from her tribe her
entire life she doesn't know why she
doesn't know where her family is she
doesn't understand why the other kids
throw rocks at her or what she's done to
make the other Nora refuse to speak to
her
it's really quite devastating to watch
her suffer through it all as she grows
up but it's all of these things that
shape a laws motivations to be accepted
into the tribe find her mother and
understand the things that have been
kept from her the main game kicks off
with a LOI as a fully grown young woman
who is very much the product of her
childhood with a deep love for her
guardian and deep-seated mistrust for
everybody else she initially treats
strangers with frustration but this
changes with the new people and events
gl
Valley on a lie isn't very kind to the
people she meets unless they're
obviously in need and her natural
compassion kicks in she's generally a
suspicious person after speaking to an
innkeeper who's retelling of a recent
event doesn't seem quite right she's
quick to point out that he seems Shady a
lawyer is smart and resourceful a fact
that her friends never failed to remind
her of but she also struggles to make
connections and masks her discomfort in
engaging with people with sarcasm and
spaz I've heard a lot of my friends say
that a boy talks too much is too
judgmental too sassy or spends too much
time bitching about the weather but you
know who else spends a lot of time
bitching about the weather you do or at
least I do it's a simple touch that I
think makes a law a whole lot more
relatable if you've been bullied or know
what it's like to be on the outside of
social groups looking in I'm betting
you'll understand her standoffish and
guarded tendencies turf when alloy does
begin to open up it's really
heartwarming you can see other
characters earning her trust you watch
friendships form you feel her genuine
pain when she empathizes with an NPC
over a tragic situation like the loss of
a family member a lot of that is due to
Ashley birches excellent voice work but
Ayla is also just an exceptionally
well-written character she's not afraid
to pull someone up for flirting with her
or disrespecting her for being a woman
or Nora hey Louise confidence rarely
wavers and she doesn't take [ __ ] and
that's exactly the kind of character you
want to be playing when you have to
fight menacing towering machines alloy
is consistently tough and independent
and what she learns on her travels is
the importance of letting people help
her and trusting people enough to be
part of a community again after
finishing horizon you might feel like I
do I spent about 50 hours with a Lloyd
getting to know her and eventually
closing the book on her story and I miss
her and that's awesome
you
[Music]